madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce samedi 25 août
philippe léotard est mort aujourd'hui
dans une clinique parisienne des suites
d'une insuffisance respiratoire
à quelques jours de son 61e anniversaire
l'acteur frère de françois léotard
ancien ministre de la défense
actuellement en poste en macédoine avait
été hospitalisé à plusieurs reprises
circulation dense mais pas trop de
bouchons sur la route des retours le
grand embouteillage redouté par bison
futé ne s'est pas produit
c'est surtout la canicule qui a gêné les
automobilistes et accentuer la pollution
cherche chambre à louer sans succès à
paris il devient de plus en plus
difficile de trouver un studio ou un
petit appartement à la location
à oslo une nouvelle princesse
mette-marit a épousé cet après midi le
prince haakon de norvège
une sorte de rêve parti pour cette jeune
fille au passé tumultueux philippe
léotard 60 ans est décédé aujourd'hui à
paris l'acteur frère de françois léotard
ancien ministre de la défense avait été
hospitalisé depuis plusieurs jours dans
un hôpital
ses obsèques devraient avoir lieu mardi
philippe léotard acteur à la carrière
féconde s'était aussi rendu célèbre pour
ses prises de position parfois
iconoclaste qu sa voix rauque son
penchant pour l'alcool et les drogues
dont il ne se cachait pas proche de son
frère en dépit de leurs divergences de
carrière philippe léotard tournait
régulièrement à sanary françois léotard
son frère actuellement en poste en
macédoine est attendu à paris portrait
avec olivier linot de ça c'était un
capitaine un pirate à la barre d'un
bateau ivre un vieux loup de mer échoué
sur un récif trop gros pour lui la vie
cette vie qu'il aimait tant
il disait j'ai fait pour me taire lui
qui s'était tourné vers l'écriture vers
la chanson lui à qui le cinéma ne
proposaient plus rien ou plus grand
chose
philippe léotard débuta sa carrière en
1970 avec truffaut et puis il y eut
sauté
max et les ferrailleurs philippe léotard
impose sa gueule sont jeudi de la lande
eu un rien calculer un titre qui la rend
lundi qu'il a rendus à noter qu'il a
revendue à carmaux nancy s'est décrochée
et puis signe du destin le bon flic se
transforme en voyou en mac dans la
balance
ça laisse des traces resnik en 1982 la
balance s'offre à philippe léotard le
césar du meilleur acteur
ce concours est fragile trop à fleur de
peau l'acteur consume son talent dans
des paradis artificiels mais bien réel
la drogue l'alcool fumée blanche pour
écran noir ligne de douleur comme couche
mais pleurez tout doucement l'écorché
vif trempé sa plume dans sa rage de
vivre son désir d'exister amis de deux
verres de gainsbourg de coluche frère de
françois l'ancien ministre de la défense
fils et plus s'était proclamé ministre
de la défonce
il aimait brûler la vie par les deux
bouts certains retiendront de lui une
image déglingué titubante monsieur
léotard était en fait un homme à la
sensibilité exacerbée une tendresse
fragile lui le clown au regard souvent
tristes la terrasse de l'auberge de la
gabrielle hallinger dans l'indre était
bondée aujourd'hui lorsqu après le
déjeuner un conducteur a fait une fausse
manoeuvre
hélas perdu le contrôle de son véhicule
et a reculé au milieu des convives
dix sept personnes ont été blessées dont
cinq grièvement
une antenne de secours d'urgence a été
installé sur place alors que les blessés
les plus graves avaient été évacués par
hélicoptère michel chine
c'est cette voiture qui a provoqué le
drame
son conducteur aurait fait une fausse
manoeuvre perdu le contrôle du véhicule
il aurait foncé en marche arrière sur ce
restaurant les dizaines de personnes qui
déjeuner sur la terrasse de cette
auberge en bordure d'un étang n'ont pas
eu le temps de réagir
on veut pas dire grand chose on veut de
l'étranglement train de manger et puis
on s'est trouvé en fait trouvé sous la
table tous les voitures sous la voiture
sans savoir
cet accident plutôt inhabituel a fait 17
blessés dont cinq graves les secours les
ont évacués vers des hôpitaux de la
région par hélicoptère la rotation c'est
la chance car on veut savoir c'est qu'en
territoire qui décolle avec la victime
au conte 40 minutes et on a leur
délégation à suivre cet après midi à
l'heure du drame
l'auberge de la gabrielle au bord de cet
étang de l'indre été particulièrement
fréquenté à cause d'une foire qui se
tenait tout près de la fusillade dans le
centre de guingamp tôt ce matin en
pleine rue un jeune homme de 26 ans a
été tuée de douze balles tirées par une
arme automatique
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
le meurtrier présumé et sa victime se
serait bagarré à la sortie d'une boîte
de nuit les recherches ont aussitôt été
engagés pour tenter d'interpeller
l'auteur des coups de feu qui a pris la
fuite
jacques devaux et larbi benchiha le
drame s'est joué au petit matin sur le
palier de cette maison située près du
centre ville de guingamp
une vive altercation oppose deux hommes
qui semble-t-il se connaissent l'un
d'eux retourne chez lui à quelques
dizaines de mètres de là et revient avec
une arme automatique
il fait plus une dizaine de fois la
victime âgée de 27 ans est tué sur le
coup dans le quartier la surprise est
totale j'ai pas m'en plaindre
enak de qui m'embête c'est le chien qui
gueulent la nuit
quand les parents sont pas là ou bep cap
lui survivront autrement je parle pas du
tout du tout du tout l'été durant pitt
la matinée le gipn a bouclé le quartier
pensons que le meurtrier s'était peut
être barricadée chibli la vérification a
été fait
l'individu ne se trouvait pas dans les
vieux c'est vrai parti juste après avoir
comme il serait parti restera à vérifier
pour l'heure le meurtrier présumé un
homme d'une cinquantaine d'années n'a
toujours pas été localisé le srpj de
rennes est chargée de l'enquêté
il devra déterminer dans quelles
circonstances s'est déroulé le drame
trafic dense sur les routes françaises
aujourd'hui pour ce dernier week-end du
mois d'août mais la circulation est
restée relativement fluide en dépit d'un
samedi annoncé rouge il n'y a pas eu de
gigantesques bouchons
c'est dans la vallée du rhône que les
automobilistes ont été le plus nombreux
dans les deux sens
ralentissements et embouteillages aussi
autour de bordeaux et entre lille et
dunkerque
et pour inciter les automobilistes à
conduire prudemment il n'y a pas que les
radars
les gendarmes de la brigade rapide
d'intervention d'aubagne sillonnent
l'autoroute à bord d'une 306
surpuissante pour repérer ceux qui
conduisent mal et se comporte mal excès
de vitesse téléphone au volant
circulation sur la bande d'arrêt
d'urgence
cette année sont épaulés par un
hélicoptère qui leur signale les
infractions qu'il constate caroline
gauthier venoix jourdan et françois
pagès sur l'autoroute a8 avec les
gendarmes des brigades rapides
d'intervention c'est son nom rapide on
est fille 230 km au compteur on vitesse
de pointe pour traquer les mauvais
conducteurs bien sûr patrice pilote
aujourd'hui le véhicule le regard plus
affûté que jamais cet après midi ils
disposent en plus du soutien d'un
hélicoptère
les adeptes de la voie centrale sont
l'une des cibles des gendarmes
sans argent sur eux pour payer l'amendé
ces italiens en seront quittes pour une
leçon de conduite
en quoi la voie du milieu simplement
faire du bruit
d'accord denis l'infraction de
comportement ont été relevés l'an
dernier par les six gendarmes de la br i
d'aubagne une chasse quotidienne où
l'hélicoptère pourrait bien trouver sa
place l'intérêt des idées très claires
c'est d'avoir un champ de vision sur sur
l'autoroute qui soit beaucoup plus
élargie que celui qu'on peut avoir au
sol d'un véhicule d'une auto de pouvoir
anticiper sur les évènements aussi bien
sur un ralentissement que sur un
accident est également de pouvoir bien
sûr signaler aux équipes au sol le
comportement éventuellement la fraction
de tel ou tel automobilistes l'harmonie
branche grass track et l'angola
formés au pilotage la brigade rattrapera
finalement le véhicule
la suite se passe de commentaires je
vais vous relevez le défaut de réduction
de la vitesse
d'accord steve hansen et simplement ou
l'allemande professeur 2 931 le noir
géant l'abri
mais bon c'est une voiture qui marchent
vite aussi donc pas toujours évident pas
évident surtout que maintenant la menace
peut aussi venir du ciel
une raison supplémentaire de lever le
pied il de retarder encore un peu la
rentrée
la chaleur tout à fait exceptionnelle de
ce dernier week-end d'août et l'absence
de vent entraîne une pollution à l'ozone
sur une large partie de la france à
strasbourg à paris ou à marseille mais
aussi dans le nord et en auvergne le
seuil d alerte a été franchie on
recommande donc aux personnes âgées et
aux enfants d'éviter toute activité
physique et de choisir plutôt de rester
à l'ombre des maisons fraîche demain le
temps devrait tourner à l'orage sur la
moitié ouest les températures resteront
élevées mais le tonnerre pourrait
gronder plus tous traumatisés les
passagers de l'airbus de la compagnie
canadienne air transat qui sont arrivés
ce matin à lisbonne
hier ils ont fait un atterrissage
d'urgence aux açores l'avion qui faisait
la liaison toronto lisbonne avec 300
personnes à bord s'est posé en
catastrophe sur la base militaire de la
res après avoir manqué de très peu
l'amerrissage olivier caroff des
miraculés du ciel accueillis par leurs
proches à l'aéroport de lisbonne 291
passagers est un héros il a préféré ne
pas se montrer mais chacun parle de lui
le pilote extraordinaire c'est celui de
cet airbus d'une compagnie canadienne il
s'est posé en catastrophe sur la piste
d'un petit aéroport des açores il a
surtout réussi à éviter un crash en
plein océan parti de toronto la nuit
dernière le vol 236 devait rejoindre
lisbonne en pleine traversée l'airbus
a330 comme celui ci perd tout son
carburant une fuite puis les deux
moteurs tombe en panne
l'avion devient une masse inerte 200
tonnes qu'il faut maintenir en l'air
comme un planeur le pilote va tenir
ainsi 18 minutes une éternité avant de
rejoindre la piste la plus proche
la manoeuvre nécessite beaucoup de
sang-froid et encore plus d'expérience
il s'agit vraisemblablement d'un pilote
et y était fort mais il y a plus d'une
dizaine d'années car aujourd'hui
malheureusement les contraintes
financières sont telles que les jeunes
pilotes qui rentre dans les compagnies
aériennes et qui accèdent à leur
première avion de ligne n'ont que
quelques heures de formation sur
l'appareil quelques heures durant
lesquelles ils n'ont pas le temps de
faire ce type d'exercice seuls dégâts
visibles les pneus éclaté à
l'atterrissage
une enquête est en cours pour comprendre
les causes de la fuite de carburant
c'est un immense espoir pour les malades
cardiaques à düsseldorf en allemagne des
cardiologues ont pu reconstituer avec
succès une partie du coeur dans malades
avec ses propres cellules souches
l'expérience a eu lieu en mars dernier
alors que le patient âgé de 46 ans avait
été victime d'un infarctus qui avaient
détérioré en partie le muscle cardiaque
dorothée cochard on avait réussi
l'opération sur des souris il fallait la
réussir sur l'homme en allemagne à
düsseldorf
un homme est en train de recouvrer
l'usagé de son coeur grâce à l'injection
de cellules souches les cellules souches
ce sont des cellules qui n'ont pas
encore de rôles définis dans l'organisme
et qui peuvent se transformer en
n'importe quelle cellule des nerfs du
foie des eaux ou des muscles et c'est ce
qui s'est passé à düsseldorf les
chirurgiens helmand ont injecté ces
fameuses cellules souches dans le coeur
d'un patient victime d'un infarctus
ces cellules ont se transforment en
cellules du coeur ont en quelque sorte
réparer les dégâts causés par
l'infarctus et cette opération est un
réel espoir
jusqu'ici on trouvait ces cellules dans
les embryons humains en prélevant cette
fois ci dans la moelle épinière d'un
adulte les savants espère éviter la
polémique liée à la manipulation
d'embryons humains pour la recherche
premièrement on ne risque pas vraiment
de gros problèmes éthiques parce que les
cellules proviennent du patient lui-même
et deuxièmement on limite les risques de
rejet puisque les cellules proviennent
du corps de ce malade
à vrai dire cette première n'en est pas
vraiment une
il y a un an des chercheurs français
avait déjà réussi une telle opération à
partir de cellules prélevées sur une
cuisse qui nouveau avec cette opération
c'est que les savants se rendre compte
qu'on peut t'on prélever un peu partout
dans l'organisme
un formidable espoir thérapeutique il
est de plus en plus difficile de trouver
un appartement à paris
avec la hausse des prix de l'immobilier
beaucoup de propriétaires préfèrent
vendre et l'arrivée des jeunes diplômés
sur le marché du travail accentue encore
cette pénurie
les locataires se pressent à nouveau
dans les cages d'escaliers à la moindre
annonce enquête avec virginie timothy
kaine et julie à frire trouver un
appartement à louer à paris c'est plutôt
sportif du studio au 5 pièces les
logements offerts à la location sont de
plus en plus rares résultat les prix des
loyers plombe près de 2,6 pour cent
d'augmentation en un an et les exigences
des propriétaires sont de plus en plus
importante
jean paul legrand ton banques la carte
d'identité des parents on va car deux
entités au bulletin de salaire votre
contre eux manque aussi un camp de
personnes en même temps pour visiter une
chambre de bonne cet après midi à
montmartre
nous avons au téléphone son annonce vous
me rappelez d'accord et on ira les voir
ensemble autres mais cette propriétaire
n'a pas que cet appartement à vendre
elle enchaîne les rendez-vous les uns
après les autres
dans les agences immobilières le marché
locatif est bloqué depuis un an
le studio en ce moment une seule offre
de location pour 25 demandes
les parisiens gardent leur appartement
les banlieusards veulent retourner dans
la capitale
du coup le roulement ne se fait plus
c'est déjà le cas pour les studios c'est
déjà le cas également pour les deux
pièces pour passer des choses qu'on lie
comme à satisfaire les gars en ce qui
nous concerne avec notre organisation
l'arrière à satisfaire 70 75 % des
clients qui se présentent une dans les
surfaces qui vont jusqu'à 60 mètres
carrés au delà il est bien évident qu'on
est deux dans les mêmes qu'à condition
que les hausses et avec de grandes
randonnées pour tous les apporteurs
et les agences ont bougé onglet avec la
crise les files d'attentes sont de plus
en plus longues
les appartements sont loués avant même
d'être visité les candidats à la
location sont découragés le petit peu
désespéré
et avec la rentrée universitaire qui
approche la situation n'est pas près de
s'améliorer
le président jacques chirac gagne 6
points dans le barème de popularité ifop
jdd avec 60% de personnes qui se dit
satisfaite au lieu de 54 % en juillet le
premier ministre perd un point elle
recueille 48% d'opinions favorables les
mécontents passe de 36 à 44 %
manifestation des sans papiers
aujourd'hui à paris cinq ans après
l'occupation de l'église saint-bernard
et l'évacuation musclée des centaines de
sans papiers ils étaient près de 2000
environ aujourd'hui à réclamer la
régularisation pour tous
reportage dorothée cochard et yann
moines saint-bernard cet après midi une
manifestation aux allures de pèlerinage
ils sont plus d'un millier à commémorer
l'expulsion des sans-papiers de cette
église du xviiie arrondissement de paris
souvenez vous c'était il ya cinq ans 314
africains occupent l'église
certains font la grève de la faim pour
obtenir des papiers quand des crs
pénètre temps en force
les ex plus violemment deux ans plus
tard la loi chevènement les régularise e
et 81 mille autres clandestins
mais pour les manifestants c'est loin
d'être suffisant la loi se gagnent dans
lequel elle continue à créer du jour non
expulsables
on régularisables donc ça maintient des
hommes dans une précarité qui est
vraiment atroce c'est la mondialisation
chez nous face et la loi chevènement
parmi les manifestants fatma arrivait
17,1 en france elle n'est jamais
retourné en tunise mariée mère de deux
enfants elle n'est légalement pas
excusable mais elles n'arrivent pas à
obtenir le titre de séjour jelasic je ne
sais pas pourquoi c'est la quatrième
fois que je roulais leurs films
je sais pas je ne vois pas pourquoi pour
moi comme fat mike cent soixante trois
mille en france à se voir refuser un
titre de saison cinq ans après saint
bernard
leur mot d'ordre reste le même
spectaculaire incendie hier soir à paris
dans un entrepôt des restos du coeur
près de la place de la bastille par
mesure de sécurité une cinquantaine de
riverains ont été évacués
12 caserne de pompiers étaient mobilisés
avec lou centaines d'hommes et 28
véhicules les réserves alimentaires de
cet entrepôt de 800 mètres carrés ont
évidemment été totalement détruite
deux policiers suisses mise en examen
par le parquet de mulhouse pour
violences volontaires ayant entraîné la
mort
hier il avait pris en chasse abalain
jeunes français soupçonnés de vol
les deux policiers suisses l'avait
poursuivie jusqu'en france est abattu
dans sa voiture au moment de
l'interpellation tendu par la préfecture
du haut rhin
il avait fait valoir un droit de
poursuite pour avoir pénétré sur le
territoire français et expliqué qu'il
avait agi en légitime défense
en macédoine les forces de l'otan
devraient commencer la semaine prochaine
à collecter les armes de la guérilla
albanaise de loups checa il achève pour
l'instant les préparatifs de cette
mission dite moi sont essentiels
nos envoyés spéciaux bertrand cocq et
patrick desmulie sont allés aujourd'hui
dans la montagne visite à un village
contrôlée par lou checa et voir dans
quel état d'esprit se trouvent les
rebelles albanais
au nord de tetovo d'auberoche dresse son
minaret au coeur du territoire albanais
de la macédoine depuis deux mois c'est
l'un de ces villages contrôlée par lou
checa la guérilla albanaise à
d'auberoche les armes sont partout le
morceau de choix c'est ce blindés
transports de troupes ont pris à la
police militaire macédonienne le mois
dernier si ça ne tenait qu'à moi dit
hussein j'en ferai un monument
historique
un monument à la gloire de nos armes
hussein est l'un des commandants ou
checa du secteur de d'auberoche avant
les affrontements
il enseignait l'histoire à tetovo le
prof c'est son nom de guerre montrent
inspecter ses positions dans la montagne
presque à portée de fusil du kosovo un
poste de combat
une demi-douzaine de mon homme bien
cachés sous les châtaigniers à les
croire ils n'ont pour se défendre que
leurs armes individuelles
rien de plus conséquent que ces fusils
pris à l'ennemi
c'est probablement inexactes en tout cas
impossible à vérifier que ce sont ces
armes que les hommes de lucescu
s'apprête à rendre à l'otan ces jours ci
sont des kalach nikov russes chinoises
on en trouve partout dans les balkans
elles sont aisément remplaçable mais
avant de songer à déposer les armes
le prof tient à nous faire visiter son
bunker il dit qu'il conservera ce
témoignage de la guerre pour
l'édification des générations futures
mais il fait confiance à l'otan pour
ramener la paix dans son pays
alain cassel diane déry je ne crois pas
que la guerre reprendra dit il mais si
c'était le cas les armes c'est pas ce
qui manque dans les balkans et nous
n'hésiterions pas à nous en procurer de
nouvelles
si tout se passe comme le souhaite la
communauté internationale hussein ne
devrait pas tarder à quitter l'uniforme
et a retrouvé son lycée mais le prof
d'histoire c'est que la haine a tracé
son sillon entre les communautés et que
l'adieu aux armes ne figure pas vraiment
parmi les traditions locales
ce matin à l'aube à gaza deux
palestiniens ont attaqué une position
militaire israélienne qui défendent est
une colonie juive
ils ont tué trois soldats avant d'être
même abattu à la suite de cette attaque
l'armée israélienne a bouclé le sud de
la bande de gaza la population
palestinienne redoutent une riposte
militaire
la vie est de plus en plus compliquée
pour tous y compris les colons
israéliens bien sûr qu'ils se sentent
menacés et nous plus circuler tant les
routes sont dangereuses
au point que certains aujourd'hui
souhaitent partir ils sont encore une
minorité les colonies continuent à se
développer mais à un rythme moins
soutenu agnès vahramian et jean-françois
renou ont rencontré une jeune femme qui
a quitté son implantation près de
bethléem pour vivre à jérusalem raid va
emménager à jérusalem il ya quinze jours
depuis elle redécouvre des plaisirs
simples le cinéma le théâtre le soir
depuis septembre elle lui avait renoncé
pour rentrer et sortir de sa colonie les
routes étaient devenues trop dangereuses
ses trois enfants ne circulait même plus
dans sa voiture mais en bus blindé alors
lé parc c'est dur quad a tangué but
c'est aussi d'envoyer les enfants tout
seul c'était j'étais inquiète tout le
temps j'attendais que qu'ils appellent
pour dire s'ils sont bien arrivés au nom
très stressant je sais que les autres et
ce ton
j'ai eu un sentiment de de trahison
jammes quelquefois j'ai un sentiment
d'avoir trahi mes idéaux
la route que red pas hésité à emprunter
c'est celle ci elle passe sous bethléem
ville palestinienne des collines des
tireurs embusqués visent régulièrement
des voitures de colons au bout de la
route
les implantations descoings est une des
plus isolés sa marque commercialise ici
les nouvelles constructions
elles vont une certaine qualité de vie
un esprit d'entraidé maison moins cher
et dit elle pas moins de sécurité
qu'ailleurs je ne me sentirai pas plus
sur un jérusalem je n'aimerais pas que
mes enfants tournent aujourd'hui à
jérusalem à tel-aviv on a vu un atelier
il n'y a pas un endroit aujourd'hui où
en ce sens c'est correct
trois familles seulement ont fait leurs
valises et pas tout pour des questions
de sécurité mais les clients de
l'extérieur sont rares ceux qui veulent
acheter son comme ce jeune homme né ici
si j'étais persuadé qu'en partant d'ici
il y aurait la paix je pars en courant
parce que j'aime la paire mais ça
n'arrivera pas ils veulent nous jeter
dehors
à tekoa des ouvriers palestiniens
servent de main d'oeuvre sous
surveillance la colonie est au milieu de
villages arabes en cisjordanie la
croissance des implantations se poursuit
mais à un rythme ralenti et les départs
touche les plus fragiles en mai dernier
deux enfants de tekoa ont été lapidés
assassiné par des palestiniens dans ce
canyon dans la colonie aux portes du
désert se préfabriquer accueille deux
rouleaux de la torah et une synagogue en
leur mémoire partir serait pour ces
colons trahir leurs souvenirs
condamné à mort il ya dix huit ans
chance fine a été libéré hier d'une
prison de l'idaho aux états unis en 1982
il avait été accusé de viol et de
meurtre pour une sur une petite fille de
9 ans grâce aux tests adn il vient
d'être innocenté
à sa sortie il a déclaré qu'il ne tenait
pas rigueur à la justice américaine
olivier galzi il n'en revient toujours
pas alors il remercie dieu pour avoir
inventé le test adn
un simple test qui vient de lui rendre
sa liberté après 18 années passées dans
les couloirs de la mort je ne sais pas
quoi dire c'est tellement nouveau le je
m'étais habitué à ma condamnation à mort
l'histoire de cet homme tient qu'à un
cheveu un cheveu retrouvé en 82 sur le
corps d'une fillette violée tuée à
l'époque une preuve suffisante pour le
condamner jusqu'à ce qu'un test adn
viennent prouver que ce cheveu n'était
pas le sien
ceci est une copie de l'ordre de
libération de mon client de classe et
une libération que l'avocat peut exhiber
fièrement c'est la 97e fois qu'un
condamné à mort est innocenté aux états
unis de quoi relancer outre atlantique
l'épineux débat sur la peine capitale en
corse et les éleveurs de moutons
s'inquiètent de l'ampleur que prend
l'épizootie de fièvre catarrhale en
haute-corse plus d'un millier de
cadavres d'animaux ont été retrouvés
dans la nature sans compter ceux qui
sont ou ont été enlevés par les bergers
les éleveurs estiment que les mesures
d'urgence prises hier par jean glavany
sont nettement insuffisantes sur place
notre envoyé spécial au didier théron
hinault belgique manifesté les premiers
symptômes il hier soir regardez sa
bouche elle est déjà dans un état
lamentable
les naseaux sont complètement obstruée
déjà la déformation de la tête qui
commence à se faire et cette bête là je
pense qu'elle ne passe pas quatre
la fièvre catarrhale ne laisse aucune
chance aux moutons corse après une
courte incubation les défenses
immunitaires s'affaiblissent c'est la
septicémie un virus inoculé par une
petite mouche la colique aux ide est à
l'origine de l'épizootie l'insecte vient
d'afrique et profite du réchauffement
climatique pour s'installer chaque fois
un peu plus au nord
des cas de fièvre ont déjà été recensées
dans le cantal
jean pierre ottavi et éleveur de moutons
de race corse il est excédé car rien n'a
été fait pour prévenir le retour de
l'épizootie qui a frappé la corse d'eva
l'an dernier ce qui est déplorable c'est
qu'effectivement peut-être qu'avec deux
mesures très simples de démystification
désinsectisation des péris des pacages
comme le font nos voisins lessard de
d'ailleurs il ya qu'à voir les moyens
qui sont mises en oeuvre en sardaigne
pour éradiquer
ils font tout ce qu'il faut il se
servait du coup et se servent de 4,4
avec des canons pulvérisateur et il
traite ou les marécages les plans d'eau
les lieux humides les aides tout est
traité
nous aussi on a encore vu personne à ce
jour et la fièvre catarrhale fait des
ravages depuis un an et demi déjà
les éleveurs en colère ont jeté des
carcasses devant les gendarmeries rien
n'avait été prévu pour l'équarrissage
des bêtes de mesures concrètes ont
malgré tout été prises par les pouvoirs
publics
la vaccination elle s'est avérée
inefficace la mise en quarantaine des
moutons corse interdit deux continents
une catastrophe économique
est-ce qu'on va réellement pouvoir
donner une chance à cette filière qui je
vous le rappelle notamment en plaine
orientale est véritablement la grande
celle qui occupe le terrain et l'espace
rural course si celle ci disparaît
qu'est ce qu'on va avoir à la place les
éleveurs corses espère maintenant que
l'arrivée de la fièvre sur le continent
va enfin accélérer la recherche pour
combattre sérieusement l'épizootie
il y avait beaucoup de monde sur les
plages du nord aujourd'hui la canicule
donné à malo les bains près de dunkerque
des allures de riviera 34 degrés sur la
plage et 21 dans l'eau de quoi faire
mentir toutes ces mauvaises langues qui
prétendent qu'il ne fait pas beau dans
le nord reportage
frédéric vion et dominique maes
trempez viennent la canicule qui écrase
cette plage pourrait tout à fait naître
et pourtant la méditerranée se trouve à
près de 1000 km plus au sud
nous sommes à malo les bains près de
dunkerque une des plages les plus
septentrionales de france ici l'été
s'est réveillé tard mais en pleine forme
21 degrés dans l'eau et plus de 34 à
l'ombre à moins de deux semaines de la
rentrée la crème solaire commençait à
figer dans ses plats qu'on l'a fallu la
ressortir en catastrophe pour éviter
l'insolation on habitue à un petit 19°
quoi c'est bien là la valse à de vraies
c'est trop chaud c'est beaucoup trop
chaud mais non monsieur ne fait jamais
trop chaud on sait que dans quelques
jours les vacances seront terminées avec
elle le farniente une perspective bien
peu réjouissantes
n'allez pourtant qu'à prendre la cour là
on compte là on respire là on a dit
henri voilà c'est en profite à fond pour
ce que la chaleur incommode vraiment il
existe de toutes façons lille est un
moyen de se rafraîchir les seuls en fait
qu'ils ont vraiment le droit de se
plaindre
ce sont ceux qui travaillent pourquoi
vous les enlevez bas avec la chaleur qui
fut en fait les cartes assure toute
molle et devenir tellement le son chaud
des départs que ça fonde et si dunkerque
ne peut rivaliser que quelques jours par
an avec la côte d'azur c'est en fait
très bien comme ça car c'est quand on a
longtemps désiré le soleil on s'est
vraiment l'apprécier
5e journée du championnat de france de
football avec à 20 heures le coup
d'envoi d'un match attendu bastien
marseille mais à bordeaux le match
avancé contre auxerre vient à l'instant
de se terminer un partout un premier but
sur coup franc de faux pauleta pour les
girondins et bourguignons ont égalisé à
la 65e minute grâce à yann lachuer
quatrième et dernière étape de la
solitaire du figaro
les 38 skippers sont partis à la
mi-journée du port irlandais de dingle
pour une dernière manche
particulièrement longue qui les amènera
un monde aille au pays basque
arrivée prévue jeudi avec une météo
incertaine qui donnera un peu de sel à
cette dernière course plus délicat mais
tout aussi sérieux le championnat du
monde de billes sur sable se déroule à
royan c'est un jeune bulgare de 16 ans
mylène dimitrov qui a remporté le titre
en devançant le français pierre yves
lazure 37 ans le parcours véritables
oeuvres artistiques d'une centaine de
mètres a nécessité 40 tonnes de sable
pierre ludovic viola et patrice verchère
des truelles des taloches et pourtant
ces hommes n'ont rien à voir avec la
maçonnerie c'est sculpteur sur sable ont
une mission fabriquer le plus beau
circuit sur le championnat du monde de
billes avec la politique
déjà la création à l'idée déjà repéré un
petit peu l'endroit
et puis est bien c'est de faire les
squelettes donc c'est de déplacer des
tonnes et des tonnes de sable afin
d'arriver à approcher un petit peu au
plus près du circuit final le circuit
final le voici près de cent mètres de
longueur
un parcours semé d'embûches pour les
joueurs transformés en aventurier des
pyramides et de la jungle africaine
le parcours comme comme comme chaque
année des idées splendide
j'ai vraiment ce qu'ils ont et
décoration c'est vraiment un plaisir de
jouer enfin un parcours comme celui là
parmi les participants il y a les
enfants et surtout les grands gamins
le plus jeune a 10 ans le plus vieux 49
il n'y a pas beaucoup de jeu il n'y a
pas beaucoup de compétition où les
parents partent à égalité de chances
avec les enfants ou l inverse
donc nous on fait une seule catégorie ce
qui fait qu'on on a régulièrement le
papa qui affronte son enfant l'escargot
la royannaise ou l'africaine
côté technique tous les coups sont
permis dernière partie à la nuit tombée
deux heures pour une finale mondiale ou
dix pays sont représentés
il n'y a plus ni jeune ni vieux juste
des enfants de la ville
changement de propriétaire sans doute à
l'olympia la famille coquatrix
propriétaire unique de cette salle
mythique parisienne devrait la vendre au
groupe vivendi universal présidée par
jean marie messier l'annoncé officielle
devrait en être faite lundi
claudine gilbert est il un cas plus qu
un music-hall une légende
la pépinière de talents uniques au monde
scène la plus convoitée des plus grandes
stars internationales
une scène désormais convoitée par le
mastodonte de l'industrie du disque
vivendi universal le groupe de jean
marie messier vend 300 millions de
disques en europe
déjà propriétaire de canal + en juin
2000 il fusionnait avec le canadien
seagram
résultat 35 % de parts de marché un
chiffre d'affaires proche de 400
milliards de francs une stratégie sans
faille le géant veut tout contrôler de
la production à la diffusion
l'olympia pour lui ce serait un autre
moyen de diffusion pour son pléthorique
catalogue d'artistes
ce serait aussi une inestimable vitrine
mais l'olympia depuis un demi siècle
c'était autre chose
le berceau des figures mythiques de la
chanson française est une authentique
aventure artistique et familiale celle
des coquatrix en 69 à la mort du
fondateur bruno coquatrix sa femme et sa
fille à des repris le flambeau
mais aujourd'hui le clan se déchire il
doit abandonner le joyau du boulevard
des capucines l'olympia entre de plain
pied dans le monde de la culture
industrielle
c'est l'un des derniers témoins de l'âge
d'or de la chanson française tenue
virginale pour la nouvelle princesse de
norvège précédé par son fils de 4 ans
habillé en page
elle est entrée dans la cathédrale
d'oslo bras de son futur époux le prince
a con le gotha européen s'était donné
rendez vous aujourd'hui à oslo pour
assister à ce mariage
après les explications publiques de la
future épouse aux origines modestes et
hop assez atypique
l'heure était aux réjouissances presse
de genève elle scelle son destin celui
de princesse witting à 28 ans elle qui
n'était qu'une serveuse au passé
sulfureux et pour son prince charmant à
comps prince héritier de la couronne
les norvégiens réconcilier avec leur
monarchie ont assisté nombreux à la
cérémonie ainsi que le ban et l'arrière
ban des têtes couronnées européennes
ici le prince edward et son épouse la
limousine ont remplacé depuis longtemps
les carrosses et les crues le blanc de
la robe de la mariée lui très digne dans
son uniforme d'officier de marine
accueille sa chère et tendre aux portes
de la cathédrale d'oslo
à l'intérieur les attentes déjà le roi
harald et la reine sonja
dernière ligne droite avant d'accéder au
rêve de princesse mais pour cela elle a
dû faire amende honorable confessant une
jeunesse tumultueuse
un ange passe marius quatre ans née
d'une précédente relation
aujourd'hui petit prince sourire figé de
rigueur pour le couple princier à
l'extérieur libérez ils livrent leur
amour au grand jour comme au cinéma
les norvégiens ont ensuite accompagné
les jeunes mariés jusqu'au palais royal
au balcon le prince charmant
la princesse de norvège et le petit
marius qui n'attend plus qu'un petit
frère ainsi se termine ce journal je
vous en rappelle la principale
information
philippe léotard 60 ans est décédé
aujourd'hui à paris l'acteur avait été
hospitalisé depuis plusieurs jours ses
obsèques devraient avoir lieu mardi
philippe léotard acteur à la carrière
fikr on s'était aussi rendu célèbre pour
ses prises de position parfois
iconoclaste sa voix rauque son penchant
pour l'alcool et les drogues dont il ne
se cachait pas proche de son frère
françois ancien ministre en dépit de
leurs divergences de carrière philippe
léotard séjournait régulièrement à
sanary françois léotard actuellement en
poste en macédoine est attendu à paris
et ce soir le ministre de la culture
catherine tasca se dit sonné par cette
disparition
catherine falk avait travaillé avec
philippe léotard lorsqu elle a illustré
avec patrice chéreau le théâtre des
amandiers à nanterre la ministre rend
hommage
un acteur magnifique dit-elle quelqu'un
de très généreux et de très douloureux
qui vivait son métier avec passion dans
quelques instants la météo d'isabel
martinez suivi de fort boyard quant à
moi je vous retrouve demain à 13h
excellente sent la sueur français